- Hi, I am Leo Brunnick.
I'm the Chief Product Officer at Cloudera.
Thank you for coming to this session.
You know, everybody talks about AI, right?
You have to end every sentence
with the word AI, I think.
But we're gonna show you something today
that some really smart people did
to actually help people that
are doing good out there.
To me, it's pretty inspirational.
So I'm gonna introduce the
two smart people, my two Als,
that's Alicia and Alastair.
Alicia, come on up.
Alicia's with Mercy Corps.
And Alastair, Alastair's
with the Cloudera.
Two brilliant people who help
bring this solution to life.
So I'll let you guys introduce
yourselves more fully.
So...
- Freak mode there.
- All right, so that
says, "Walk on slide."
I think we're already here.
All right.
(Alastair laughs)
Honestly, thanks.
I mean, I've had the chance to see
this what's been done on this project
and it's inspirational.
So, Alicia, why don't you
introduce yourself more fully?
- Yeah, my name is Alicia Morrison
and I'm the Senior Director
for Technology for Development
at Mercy Corps.
So Mercy Corps is a global
nonprofit humanitarian organization,
and our mission is to alleviate suffering,
poverty, and oppression
by helping people build secured, just,
and productive communities.
So we work in 35 plus
countries around the world.
We have more than 4,000 team members.
Most of those team members
are from the countries
in which they live and work,
because we do have a
really strong commitment
to localization for aid and development.
So Mercy Corps has a
specific value proposition
amongst international NGOs,
and that's called Crisis Analysis.
And what Crisis Analysis
is, is really sort of,
a team of people in a particular country
that wants to support
better humanitarian outcomes
by providing high-level analyses,
often qualitative, sometimes quantitative,
often a combination of
both of those things.
And providing products to
humanitarian decision-makers
to help them decide when and
where to apply humanitarian aid
or development resources,
whatever the case is.
So they can do a number of
different types of products,
things like context monitoring,
so looking at things
like politics, conflict,
what's happening in the country,
but also different humanitarian themes
like what's going on with agriculture.
Can we glean some information about
how agricultural production
is going this year
by looking at things like satellite data.
We also look at data products.
So again, sort of geospatial analytics,
as well as analytics on things
like conflict information.
Try to draw out patterns,
try to do analysis with social media,
and really, kind of just try to provide
as much information as possible
to the humanitarian community at large
in a particular country,
and make sure they have all
the information that they need
in order to make critical
decisions on the ground.
And this is particularly
important in contexts
that are very fast-moving,
changing very rapidly.
It's something like 80 some percent
of humanitarian decision-makers say
that data silos impact their
ability to make decisions
on a regular basis.
And so they try to bring a lot
of that information together
in order to provide insights
that will drive humanitarian
decision-making.
- I think you guys could
tell from that description
what a great use case
this is gonna be for AI.
Explain the...
Al, why don't you introduce
yourself more fully?
- Hi. Yeah, so, I'm Al.
I'm the director of one of our
professional services teams
based in Northern Europe.
I should kind of say actually,
I'm a bit of the B team here today
because the person that
should be sitting here, Rob,
who's in my team, who's
really the clever guy,
I'm not the clever guy,
he's been working on
this project with Alicia,
in fact, he's been working
with Alicia and her team now
for a couple of years, or
at least well over a year,
a year and a half, I think actually.
He was due to be here to
talk about the solution
that he's kind of designed and built.
But unfortunately, a few days ago,
his son was born somewhat prematurely
and somewhat surprisingly, only 27 weeks,
but he's doing well.
So I had to drop in in his place.
So yeah, but it's great to be here.
And, you know, I've worked with
Alicia and her teams as well
for a good year or so now,
and it's a real pleasure
to work with them.
And we've had a great
relationship with Mercy Corps now
for quite some time,
which I think is quite a good
fit, really, Alicia, isn't it?
Because, I mean, Alicia
here has got some amazing,
innovative ideas, really
stretching the boundaries
of what humanitarian
organizations can do with AI.
And obviously, at Cloudera,
we are sort of innovating
in that space as well.
And I think, you know, we sort of...
We kinda hit it off pretty well
and it's been an enjoyable partnership.
So it's been great to be part of that.
- Why don't you take us through
the history of the project?
- Yeah, so back in July '24,
there was a tech to the
rescue and organization
that kind of did a sort of
speed dating type process
to match up tech companies
with organizations like Mercy Corps.
And as Rob would always say,
he said, "We had a few okay dates,
but then we had a really
good one with Mercy Corps."
And so, this time last year,
Rob and Alicia were here
talking about a GenAI solution,
which also used RAG to kinda help
do general Mercy Corps internal people
to sort of do general research
on using natural language interfaces,
so sort of classic GenAI-type project.
And then Alicia sort of started thinking,
"Okay, what's next?"
And obviously, I think like many people,
sort of, there was the GenAI phase
and people are now moving
on to the agentic AI phase.
So Alicia came to us
with a series of kind
of problem statements.
I think there were about 250
words each, weren't there?
I think you had about four or five ideas.
Like, these are things that we reckon
might be a good fit for agentic AI.
And one of them stood out,
which was the story that
we're gonna talk about today
around Crisis Analysis.
Now, in parallel to that,
I run an initiative with
the London Business School
and some of their masters
in international management students.
So they come and do a
project with us every year,
and it's great 'cause you get
two teams of six very, very
smart, intelligent people
who've got 13 weeks to
do some work for you.
And so I went to Alicia and said,
"How do you fancy having
two teams of smart students
doing some work for you?"
She was like, "Bring it on." (chuckles)
So we asked them to look at two things,
and we'll talk about these in a bit more
as we go through the deck.
But we asked one team to look at
to take Alicia's 250-word product,
sort of problem statement,
and turn it into a series of user stories.
So they sat down with
the Crisis Analysis teams
and tried to understand a bit more
about how those teams work.
And then we also thought,
"Well, if Mercy Corps
was doing this kind of
for real as it were,
without the support of AWS and Cloudera,
what would the business case
look like, you know, to..."
'Cause the process, the
solution that we're providing,
saves a lot of time.
So let's monetize that.
Let's make sure we really
understand the business case
behind this solution.
So they did a great job
and you can see there,
you know, they presented
all of that to us.
One thing I'll say, if you get to my age,
don't ever have your photograph
taken with 12 really young,
bright, intelligent,
young master students.
'Cause if you really wanna
make yourself feel depressed,
that's the way to do it, trust me.
But it was a great piece of work,
and I think you got a
lot of value from that.
And then of course, out the back of that,
we had the user stories for the solution
that we're building,
and we're here today now to
talk about it to you guys.
- So you've mentioned this use case
and why you thought it would be ideal.
Tell us about the use case.
- Yeah, so Crisis
Analysis as we mentioned,
you know, develops a number of products.
And those products can
be on a monthly basis,
they can be on a quarterly basis,
they can be a page long,
they can be many, many pages long.
But by and large what takes time,
is developing the information
base for those reports, right?
And I think we surveyed
six different countries,
six different Crisis Analysis teams
across six different countries,
and it was something like 790 hours
are spent each month on research alone.
And so, the objective
was really kind of like
to come from this position of,
can we reduce that amount of
time spent on research alone?
And I think London Business
School was pretty ambitious,
and said, "Can we reduce it by 50%?",
and what would that look like
if we were able to do that?
So it's really kind of that acceleration,
you know, the humanitarian sector
has undergone drastic
financial transition this year,
and Mercy Corps has been
pretty heavily impacted
by that transition.
- Yeah.
- So the question isn't
how we do more with less,
but if we're not going to have funding,
what can we do with the
people that we have?
How can we best leverage their talents?
A lot of times, as funding gets cut,
analysis is the first
thing that goes, right?
And so, now you end up with data silos,
you're making decisions
with very little information in places,
where again, like information
is really critical.
And so, the question is really,
how do we maintain,
if we're not getting any
new funding, moving forward?
And that was really kind of like the basis
for our user stories.
- Yeah, we're talking about this earlier.
I was struck by the timing, right?
I mean, we started talking two years ago
and started working a year ago,
and we're demoing it tomorrow,
and now, suddenly,
it's essential just to keep doing the job.
- Yeah, for sure.
I think it's one of these things where
you can't be behind the
power curve right now with AI
because there's so much promise-
- Right.
- you know.
And again, kind of thinking
about the benefit we got
out of that LBS study that the
London Business School work,
is ultimately, what that enabled us to do,
is really run those different
financial scenarios, right?
And so, I work for the
chief financial officer.
It's really important to know
what we're spending our money on
and how that's going to ultimately,
sort of, save us dollars in the long run
because there's not a lot to go around.
- Cool.
All right. Cool in this way.
- Yeah, and obviously, so
when we took the use case,
we started to think about how
this was gonna be developed
as a technical solution.
You heard earlier that Alicia
talked about different themes.
So the analysts work very much,
you know, looking at all
these different themes.
So the agentic bit was really around,
let's make the agents behind
the solution domain experts
in each of their themes.
And there's different
themes, aren't there?
So I think there's humanitarian themes,
which I think are things
like sort of water security,
food security, so things that,
you know, obviously affect,
you know, people's humanitarian situation.
And then there's what they
call contextual themes,
which are things like conflict
and the political situation.
And I think you were
saying earlier, Alicia,
that when the agents have been using
sort of things like ChatGPT,
the analysts have been
using things like ChatGPT,
they don't really get the results back
that they're looking for.
So the idea of using the
agentic solution was,
you know, we can make each
of the agentic workflows
a domain expert.
So one agentic workflow will
be an expert in food security,
and it will prioritize data sources
related to food security
over its kind of...
The LLM won't be going
to its kind of core knowledge base first.
It'll be going to a much more
specialized knowledge base.
And obviously, over time,
we can build up the expertise
in each of those agentic workflows
so they can get better and better
based on what we learn as
we go through the process.
So it all sits just on
a kind of platform level
within Cloudera's AI solution.
And it reach, sort of,
running on AWS obviously,
on our past platform in the cloud.
And it we will reach out to Bedrock,
to use the Bedrock
capabilities there as well.
So, yeah, but it's...
I mentioned our Agent Studio offering.
Leo, you are our CPO,
you're probably better placed
to talk about it than I am.
- I've heard of it.
So, everybody understands
the context, right?
"Suddenly," and I put that in quotes
because it was really
just, you know, hyperbolic.
You know the story of lily pads?
Let me tell you that one real quick.
Imagine you live on a giant
pond in a little house,
and across the pond somewhere,
you can't even see there's a lily pad,
and overnight, the lily
pad doubles to two.
The next night it doubles to four.
It goes on and on and on like this.
And in 100 days, the lake is full.
But you don't see that it's
filling until day 98 or day 99.
Okay?
That's how hyperbolic works, right?
It springs out on you.
That's what happened a
few years ago with this,
when OpenAI released that
first, you know, GenAI model.
They said, "You know, look,
it's not ready. It has bias.
It hallucinates. Ah heck!",
and they released it.
And then eight other companies were like,
"Oh, we have one too. Let's go."
So we all reacted to it very quickly.
The first thing that
everybody did was say,
"Look, you know, put AI in our name,
put AI in the name of our product,
put a chatbot using an LLM
in whatever product that you have, (claps)
we're all AI enabled now, okay?
And then we started
getting good at it, right?
It says, "It's not about just the LLM.
It's about retrieval
augment generation." So RAG.
"Everyone's gonna do RAG.
Let's release RAG studios."
So everybody did that.
And then we said, "Okay,
it's still not good enough.
Everyone's gonna need agents."
So everyone goes and does that.
And in the context of all that going on,
the business users were in the same place.
They were like, "Nobody cares anymore
that we're in year seven
of our three-year journey to the cloud.
We gotta go with what we have now,
so let's make this thing happen."
It's in the context of all that,
that Cloudera has been
building its AI solution.
We did an acquihire, year before last,
while this was going on,
of a company called Verta,
and brought in some significant
expertise in the space.
And they've helped lead us
to a place where, frankly,
we think we have the
best solution out there
for high code,
Jupyter Notebook connected
directly into the system
to do this stuff,
those guys don't want your agents,
they don't want your anything,
'cause theirs is gonna
be better than yours,
all the way to no code.
So, you know, drag and drop
and plain language and et cetera.
And, you know, this set
of studios, frankly,
is right at the leading edge
of the things that can be done,
productized, out in the marketplace.
So that's what you guys were looking at.
- Cool.
And I think that the no-code bits
quite important for you, isn't it, Alicia,
because you're, you know, again,
talking about how limited resources.
- Yeah, I mean...
And in particular, sort of
technical resources, right?
Like our business is humanitarian aid,
so there's not a lot of
resources for IT or technology,
what we would call
technology for development,
which is more focused on our
humanitarian programming.
So our T4D team is two people. (chuckles)
So our ability to kind of
both build and manage systems
is pretty limited.
So the ability to go and use
sort of a low-code solution,
even if we don't like necessarily have to,
even if we have the skillset
to use a high-code solution,
it does save time.
It does help us retain
some of our human resources
for other things like onboarding
people into the system,
building up, you know, the
usage of the system itself
and the adoption of the system
itself out in the field,
which is arguably,
kind of the more important
role that we play.
- Right.
- And so I think
that sort of diversity
of the Cloudera solution
has been really beneficial to us where,
ultimately, we can choose to
go to your high-code solution
if we decide we need to,
but for the moment, you know,
we're doing what we can
with the drag and drop
because that's all we
really have time for.
- That's right.
- Yeah.
- [Leo] You know, do you
wanna show the solution?
Do we have the...
Yeah, there it is.
- [Alastair] Yeah, and I think...
I mean, one of the things I noticed,
'cause I mentioned at the start
that Rob had to stop work quite suddenly.
So we had to hand over
the work that he was doing
to somebody else in my team,
professional services team.
My team were mostly busy.
I have one guy in the team,
he'd never worked with
Agent Studio before,
just 'cause he works on
other parts of our stack,
but he was available.
But it was great because he was able
to pick up the work that Rob did
and get it deployed in Agent Studio.
He had to build a couple more MCP servers
and get them deployed.
I mean, he's a smart guy
'cause he's professional services guy,
but even so, he was able
to sort of pick it up
in a couple of days and, you know,
the interface makes that easy.
So our hope is that when
we've kind of completed
the first phase of the project,
we can hand over the solution
to Alicia and her team
and they will easily be able
to pick up and run with it
and develop it further.
- And one of the things that Cloudera did
was connect all the products that we have.
So we have a whole lot
of products for ingestion
and for storage and for et cetera.
Whether it's our data engineering stuff
or our data warehousing stuff,
our flow stuff using, you
know, all of our streaming,
we set all those up as agents
inside the Agent Studio.
So you're starting off with
a whole set of capabilities
as you continue to build agents
to create some pretty elegant
solutions very quickly.
- Yeah, no, it's been pretty quick
to get those agents built.
As I said, we kind of
mentioned it already,
but, you know, the beauty of
using the agentic workflows
is that for each of the...
and we'll see it in a minute,
we'll talk a little bit about
the front end a bit more,
but you'll see that the
information that the AI produces
comes back kind of categorized
into these different themes
that we talked about,
and each of those themes and these cards
that you'll see on the
next slide are driven by,
you know, an agentic workflow.
So we've got, as I say, by
the end of the solution,
we'll have a whole bunch of agents-
- So-
- all running.
- you know, I talk about technology a lot,
but when I was talking with
Alicia about what she's facing
and I'm thinking, "Oh, here's a solution,
here's a solution, here's a solution."
Like, all we're talking with about
was how you get people to use it.
I mean, you're talking
about how many countries?
- 35 plus.
- And how many language?s
- A lot. (chuckles)
- Yeah, a lot.
So just the concept
of getting people to
understand what it is,
trust it, be able to use it,
that was not something that,
honestly, I spend as
much time thinking about,
so that was very enlightening to me.
- [Alicia] Yeah, so adoption is really
sort of the key to
success in any technology,
product, or project, right?
And so, for us at Mercy Corps,
our objective is really to
create some of these tools
that people will actually
be putting to use.
If you create something that
then sits there with no users,
then you're not realizing the ROI
that London Business School
so kindly calculated for us, right?
And there's really no point to it.
It's not saving you money,
it's just costing you
money in the long run.
In the short one, really.
And so, really, it's about how
do we engage with our users
to determine what their workflows are
so that the platform
fits into that workflow.
And they're very clear about
what they want from it.
Sometimes it doesn't
always translate directly
to technical capability,
or they don't express it until
they see it on the screen
and they realize that's not
actually what my workflow is.
But they have very clear ideas
about what they want out of a platform.
Al mentioned, you know, we
have had analysts try to use
sort of publicly available
LLM-type platforms,
and they have a lot of opinions, right?
And one of those opinions is that
the data that gets surfaced
is often whatever's sponsored
by corporate sponsor
underneath the hood, right?
It's the same if you
go to a search engine,
you know, usually, it's whoever's paying
for those top line resources,
that's what comes to
the top of your search.
Or it can be based on frequency.
What are the resources people
are going to most often
that does not make them the
most accurate resources, right?
And so very often,
what's surfaced through those public tools
is not what analysts wanna see.
And they're very clear about
wanting to be able to plug
their own resources in,
to look across those resources,
for those resources to
be organized thematically
to support their report writing process.
But they're also very clear
they want kind of like
to stop at a certain point
because this is not designed
to replace analysts.
You can't replace the sort of
nuanced contextual information
that somebody who's living and breathing
the humanitarian world has, right?
When you're sitting in that country
and you're doing key informant interviews
and you're combining all
this information together,
that's when real insights happen.
And that platform is probably
never gonna get to that point.
So we wanna be clear
on what the platform can do and can't do,
and we want the workflows to support that.
And all of that has to
be really hashed out
in an iterative process.
We have to tell Rob to do one thing
and then probably tell him
to undo it the next week
because you've gotta kind of
like work through these things.
But if it doesn't support that workflow,
then there's no actual
confidence in the platform.
And so, really,
I think like we've worked
really closely with Al and Rob
to get that workflow sort of in a way,
that adoption is going to happen naturally
because it's a tool the users
have designed themselves.
And that's been a really
important part of our collaboration.
And it's the thing that
we think about the most,
is less about the technical build
and more about the adoption,
how people are gonna trust the platform,
making sure that it
fits into our workflows
so that the sustainment of the platform
makes sense in the long run.
- [Leo] Yeah, I mean,
I was overwhelmed by some of the things
that you were saying.
Simple example, is you
guys have to rely on
what's happening in social media
for a sense of what's
going on in the country,
what's going on in the
ground, latest stuff,
and then you were in
disinformation, right?
So if you've got an LLM out
trying to do that for you,
it's not gonna know the difference.
- [Alicia] Yeah.
- [Leo] So yeah,
I always thought that was
pretty daunting stuff.
And the ability to tell an agent
what sources to trust and et cetera,
I mean, that was interesting.
- Yeah, I mean, this is in particular
Democratic Republic of the Congo.
Unfortunately, there's a lot
of violence against NGOs,
specifically because there's a
lot of rumors on social media
and on the internet.
And so, what our team does there
is looks at both social medias
as well as traditional media sources,
triangulates those things,
and is able to kind of then combat
some of that misinformation,
make it safer for implementation,
and also identify when it's not safe
to do humanitarian implementation.
But that's a lot of sources
to go after at one time.
And collecting that all in one place,
enabling them to scan across,
sort of all of those different resources,
is something that's really
powerful in terms of time saving
and their ability to spend
their time on analysis
versus information gathering.
- Got it. Got it.
- Yeah.
- Nice.
- So, as I was saying,
it's something that I think
we've been learning really
quickly through this process,
is actually getting the right data sources
for each of the different themes,
and then understanding, you know,
the nuances between those data sources
and how that might change and how...
You know, ultimately, we're not there yet,
but a scenario where the analysts
can maybe add more data sources into,
you know, themselves dynamically so that,
you know, if there's new
data sources that comes along
or they hear something
on a social media feed
that they weren't using previously,
they can bring those in as well.
So it's a very dynamic situation,
and trying to understand, as I say,
get the way that the system
brings the data back to the users
in a way that they can
interact and understand.
You know, we don't want it,
for example, to over summarize
some of the stuff because,
you know, they need to see, like you said,
more of the detail so that they can then
actually understand what that means
and triangulate the
various different sources.
So it's gonna be an ongoing journey.
But I think they've engaged
really well with it so far, haven't they?
We've had some good feedback already from-
- [Alicia] (chuckles) Yeah, we have.
Both good and bad. (laughs)
- Yeah.
- We've had a lot of feedback.
- Good.
- [Alicia] And we'll
get there, eventually.
But yeah, I think it
just emphasizes sort of,
you know, one of flexibility
of the platform on the back end
that we're able to kind
of craft those agents
in a way where they're
pretty easily configurable.
And then also that sort of
user-centered design process
that we've been using, I think.
Those two pieces are really highlighting
how this project is gonna
ultimately be a success.
- [Alastair] Cool.
And essentially, I mean,
the flow's fairly straightforward really
is because the analyst will know
what they want to do initially.
They'll know what
questions they want to ask,
what information they're
after, so they can...
You know, they just need to
select their region first
and then it'll bring back everything
related to all the different themes,
and then they can start to drill down
into the area that they're interested in.
They can then have
a natural language
conversation with the agent
to ask it more specific questions.
So it's kind of a...
I kinda see it as a big funnel,
you know, and it's just slowly
kind of refining down the information.
And they can just get it to a point where
it's where they need
to either lift and shift
it into their report
or kind of do more
analysis on specific bits
and then add their own
conclusions from the data.
So, it's really just a three-step flow
to kinda help them, say,
triangulate and narrow down.
It's pretty straightforward, isn't it?
- [Leo] Yep.
- [Alastair] So I think we're kinda
looking to future now a bit now.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so-
- Let's talk a little bit about
where we are going from here.
This fun slide is so we
can start talking about
where we believe the
world is going, all right?
You know, when we think
about the big data, right,
termed 15 years ago.
We think of the first era of big data
being from 15 years ago to
about seven or eight years ago,
and then we call that the era of control.
And it was exactly that control
of cost, control of process,
control of a number of things,
and getting control of
large amounts of data
for the first time, when back then,
we were talking about terabytes.
Then we get into the next era
from seven or eight years ago until now.
And that second era, we call
the era of convenience, right?
It was about ease of use.
It was about getting quickly to some value
and not going through the old
IT processes of the old days.
And, you know, with convenience
came at least some loss of control.
You couldn't do some of
the things you wanted to
the way you wanted to do them.
You had to do them the way
they were out of the box.
You lost control of some of the processes
and some of the costs.
And we believe that the world
is now coming to an era of convergence
where those two things
have to be true, right?
And in order to do that,
you have to be able to,
number one, the cloud experience
is what the world expects from
all of its stuff now, right?
I want a SaaS or a SaaS
adjacent like software product.
I want it to be easy to use.
I want it to...
I don't wanna think about where stuff is,
it just magically happens out there.
So that cloud experience
has to be delivered,
it has to be consistent,
and it has to be consistent
across each of the public clouds
and across private clouds,
air-gapped environments data centers.
Okay? That's the first thing.
Second thing is, it has to...
You have to be able to do all of that
in such a way that you can
get to value in minutes,
nevermind months or
weeks, in minutes, okay?
And we're achieving that with something
that we're calling,
Anywhere Cloud, all right?
We've done a series of
acquisitions over the past year.
I mentioned an acquisition
of the AI company.
We also acquired a
company called, Octopai,
which is for a data
lineage and cataloging.
And we acquired a company called, Taikun.
And Taikun is a full
Kubernetes container system,
but it's also a environment
management system.
And we're putting that
together with the data service that we had
in this Anywhere Cloud.
In Q1, it's in tech preview.
In Q2, it releases GA,
and it is the first ever
data platform for doing AI,
but it's a disaggregated platform
because each of these services
that's fully containerized,
has a unified data fabric inside it
so they all work together,
they all talk to one another,
but they deploy independently,
and they deploy in
minutes from an interface.
And that is, we believe,
going to be game-changing
for what people need to do.
Because more and more,
it's complex data state of lots of,
you know, different vendors,
in lots of different places.
You're not moving your
data around anymore.
You've gotta be able to
do this stuff on the edge.
You've gotta be able to do it everywhere.
And we think this is the first platform
that the world has ever seen
that's gonna be able to do that.
And I like that
because when I look at the use
cases that you have, and...
I mean, you guys are
literally all over the world,
having to do things in environments
that are just blow me away, right?
And the things that we're
going to be able to do
for organizations that
have such a complex task,
I think, is very, very exciting.
- [Alicia] Yeah, that's actually
super interestingly, Leo,
because the sort of multi-cloud
conversation amongst INGOs
has been going on for
a number of years now.
We are across all of those clouds,
and then we also have a super challenging
regulatory environment.
We have places where
you can't move data outside the country,
it needs to be on data centers
inside those borders and so on.
So I think things like
that are kind of necessary
for the type of work that we do,
for the type of diversity that we have
across our organization.
And certainly-
- I can only imagine, right?
You guys hear the whole sovereign
cloud conversation, yeah?
You might have heard that.
But the fact that you are in
all those different countries,
when each of those countries
has a different rule
on sovereignty, that is just...
That's mind boggling.
- [Alicia] Well, and the rules about AI
are changing as well.
The regulatory environment
around AI, specifically,
will change as well.
So the governance around those tools
is going to be evolving rapidly
over the next few years,
and we'll have to be keeping
an eye on those things as well.
Yeah, so those types of products, I think,
are really exciting to see those
starting to actually come
out and available generally.
- [Leo] Yeah.
Look, we're coming to the
end of our prepared remarks.
We do have two microphones
wandering around in the back
or walking down the center aisle.
If anybody wants to ask any
questions before we let you go.
Please.
Come on.
- The mic's just coming.
Here it comes. (chuckles)
- There we go.
- [Audience] Hi, I was wondering,
do you guys have a particular,
like, use case or a story
of where, someone on your team,
has used this and it's made a difference?
- Yeah, that's a great
question. (chuckles)
So as Al mentioned,
our development process
was interrupted a bit by the arrival
of a charming new baby boy. (chuckles)
So we're not in a position
where we've completed as much
as we wanted to by today,
but there is currently an effort
to start using the platform
to develop some reporting for Sudan.
So our Sudan Crisis Analysis
team is a single analyst,
so he does not have a lot of bandwidth
to get done what he wants to do.
The Sudan context is extremely
dynamic, extremely volatile,
it's just extremely fragmented.
So there's a lot of different actors
in many different places doing
a lot of different things.
So they experienced some
pretty severe data silos,
information silos.
There's no sort of, like,
unified information platform
across that humanitarian effort, right?
So everybody's doing their own thing.
So there's a huge risk
of duplication of effort.
There's a huge risk of of
resource waste in that context.
So what Mercy Corps is planning to do
is to look at a report that
we've been wanting to do
for many months,
have not had the bandwidth
for that analyst to do.
It's gonna look at food
security across Sudan,
both how to evaluate current
food security situation
as well as be forward-looking
and preventing
food security problems moving forward.
And so that is sort of our goal,
is to release a report on that topic,
hopefully in the next four to six weeks.
But yeah, sorry about that. (chuckles)
We had planned to have a product done,
but unfortunately, you can't
always account for life.
We know that in
humanitarian world, so yeah.
- Cool.
- And can I just say,
please do support these guys.
I've worked with Alicia and
her team for 18 months now,
and it's humbling working with them.
They're amazing people doing amazing work.
The ideas that Alicia has
to really innovate with
technology, are phenomenal.
The the whole team...
You know, I'm always humbled and inspired
by the way that the Mercy
Corps team go about their work,
you know, in difficult,
challenging circumstances.
And it's an absolute
pleasure and a privilege
to work with them.
So yeah, please do support
the team as much as you can.
- (chuckles) So just so you know,
when you're working with
an Alicia and an Alastair,
and they both go by Al,
and when you type Al, it looks like AI,
it's impossible to write an email.
(Alastair and Alicia laughing)
So anyway, Alicia, Alastair,
thank you very much.
Thank you all for coming. Appreciate it.
- Thank you.
(audience clapping)